de quoi donner le tournis
cette pieuvre c'est l'attraction phare
cette année de la fête de la ville de
trappes
les habitants de la commune mais aussi
les voisins se sont déplacés exprès pour
l'occasion
cette famille de maurepas vient chaque
année au départ ça va très bien quand ça
bouge pas mais alors quand ça tourne ça
commence à vraiment à faire des bonnes
sensations surtout qu'en plus ça dure et
un petit peu l'otan pour moi là au début
ça tourne ça tourne vers vers un
parterre et après sa mort on dirait que
ça va tu as pris ton mille têtes
tournent manèges animations jeux mais
aussi activités sportives pendant que
certains se prenaient pour les joueurs
du mondial d'autres jouets les ouistitis
husserl ouais bah je dois faire un peu
d'escaladé la motricité surtout parce
qu'il a du mal avec la motricité donc
sale laide au delà de l'amusement cette
fête avait aussi une portée éducative
les visiteurs ont pu découvrir les
animaux dans la ferme pédagogique
on a fait un petit quizz un petit jeu
des 7 différences entre les différentes
espèces animales présentes et entre la
chèvre le mouton le coq et la poule et
puis aussi entre lan et le poney et puis
bien évidemment parler de l'animal du
respect animal comme en avant goût de
vacances avec le retour de l'été
autre rendez vous incontournable de la
ville tra plage qui revient du 9 juillet
jusqu'au 14 août